[موسيقى]
عندهم طلبات مباشره منك حول طبيعه اللقاء
مع صدام حسين كانت
الطلباتهم او الاوامر صارمه جدا
وتتجاوز حدود الجوانب الامنيه
ولم تكن مقبوله من قبليه مثل مثلا عليك ان
لا عليك عليك ان تصافحه فقط وان لا تضموا
بالضبط ولا تتبادل معه على الطريقه
العراقيه او الطريق الشرقيه
لا تحترم الرئيس
انت محامي ونحن نحترم المحاميين وهو مجرم
وضعنا طاولتين بينك وبيننا انت راح تكون
من يعني من جهه الحائط حتى ما يعني
الارتفاع للطاولات لا تسمح لي النهوض
وعدد يعني كبير من
الاوامر الصارمه
كل طبيعه هذه الطلبات والاوامر التي كانوا
يريدون ان يملوها علي
واجهتها بالرفض المطلق
[موسيقى]
اول ما دخل من الباب اني ما مقابل الرئيس
سابقا اول ما دخل يعني كان
يعني غير منتصب القامه كان يعني عنده نوع
من الحناء من الظرف الشديد يعني الظرف
القاسي اللي عمله بالامريكان او عوم
البيئي طيله سنه كامله من الاخفاء
دخل كان شعره طويل
ذقنا ايضا طويل وكان يحمل معطف على اذا
اليسرى ويحمل الحقيبه حقيبه
اليمنى فوضع
المعطف على احد الكراسي
طبعا طلعت انا حياتها ويعني
بطريقه حميميه
[موسيقى]